in this capsule we will see
the tax collector algorithm then in the
gatehouse decor closer neighbors we
previously saw one of the disadvantages
is that to make a prediction it
keep in mind all the examples
training all of which
should be maintained in
memory to be able to make a
prediction for a new example this is
it can be a problem if rather than
to have a hundred examples
we actually have in the
thousands or millions
drive copies so that
would mean that doing the research of
nearby close copies would be very
expensive in computing time so in fact
what we prefer to stay to see a way
to have a model that is capable of a
can compress the information that gets
find in our center
drive and not to require
to always consult the whole
when it comes time to
make a prediction
so what we're going to want is
a model that has bars at m that's going
adapt as we go
observe data to try
extract the relevant information from
the training set and the flu
super it's round it's an algorithm that
lets do that this is maybe a
from the first to yell learning
that was actually invented and so we're going
see it in this capsule then in the
percepts guide round the idea is to have
a model that will make a decision to
classification from a function
linear followed by a function that's
that is, for an entry x
give what they perceive will do a
time they will stop dragged on a
training set is taking a
vector x the x another actor w do
the product scala x1 rector w
so match the parameters of the
model is passed alone the result of the
school product through a function
very hot threshold that is going to be such that
if the entry of the threshold function and more
great equal to zero the output of the
servette function 1
and if not the function this they go
go back 0 so we will focus in
does it's a classification problem
binary
or appear there either 0 or 1 ok so that
this is the model behind the grid of
collector
here we have a visualization of the calculation that
is done by a tax collector so have we
here all entries ex years up
so great if it matches
elements of the vector x so our vector
x is actually a vector with
the first excellent element x 2 up
x1 is actually we can see the calculations
of the past deceives as a kind of unity
is a bit like a kind of neuron
who is connected with peas w1
up to wn at the inputs x1 up to xl and
the activation of the neuron so the la
output of the neuron your correspond to
multiply each of the expert entries
up to xn by a weight etc saint-just
this extreme case of making the sum
so we have actually corresponded to
school products wxx owes
pass this across a threshold for
check the activation of between
they exceed a certain threshold
and if it's not certain threshold our
neurons to make a species of
discharge so is worth going out healthy and if not
will remain inactive ie
come out 0 so there is a kind of
parallel to do here between this
function there and calculating a species of
artificial neurons that would be
active if its activation of basins
sun otherwise would be inactive so
go out 1-0 and the administration sees that
the arrows a bit like the connections
input neurons and a neuron from
threshold
and then the size of the arrow is
thickness it's a little here a
illustration of the size of the weight
so we could imagine that if w1
would be close to zero while w2
would be far and so that would mean that
activated the activity of the calculation on the
calculation result is much more
influenced by the value of kz2 chi x
a bigger weight than express so that
it's just an illustration it's a
example
we repaired to other arrows other
within arrows but so that's
a visual illustration of the kind of
calculation done by the collector on for
make a prediction is the vector of
weight w let's go watch it as
the parameters of our model and if these
parameters that will be adapted as
and as our father's September
to train will learn from
data
I would also like that typically
in fact we want to introduce a
certain well in the calculation that is going
actually corresponds to vary kelly the
comparison threshold so often this
what we will actually see is that rather
than to calculate wxx we will compute wx
ex plus another vector that is going to be a
another parameter that we will learn too
b so we go wxx + b and do that
it's the equivalent of not seeing a bep
here but to say that my function is
he will check if his den is there anymore
big that - p and if bigger than
less well we will return one otherwise we
will go back 0 ok so this parameter there
its its role it's a little bit of finding
what is the right threshold to have for
produce a good classification and
in swimming sometimes I would put it
not explicitly but a way of two
to have a case implementation no
explicit bias but that comes back
implicitly it's always adding
to our vectors in tree a constant
in fact the value 1 and in this case also
the connection between this constant one there
and our our calculation so it goes there the
factor the weight of this collection
their calves actually correspond to b
since we always want to have a liver b
so it's like we had wx ex more
our bias so that's the model
behind the taxman
so now commented what are we going
train the tax collector commented on this
who will adapt from a
coaching attention so we have the
equals just right here and there the idea is
that the model the tax collector we go there
shoot our training examples and
he will adapt whenever the
prediction that's going to be done will not be the
right answer
so he'll adapt eventually he goes
stop adapting as soon as he goes
return the correct answer on all
our training data
so here is the pseudo code for the
run of the algorithm so what
the tax collector we will do is that he
will shoot all excited pairs
yt who belong to our center
training and so for each in
very excited we will calculate the prediction
made by our perception so this ch of
xt which therefore corresponds to take excited
x the air product to the vectors of
weight w possibly adjusting gamer
well and get through the function
it's alas then we'll do it
difficult the prediction made by the
collector we correspond to the good
so class is what we managed to do well
predicting our target was there if we had
predicts our target we do nothing we
move on to the next example if we go
do a modification of the weights w so
each of the weights wi2wi so if the
3d elements of the vector w in drome
so we just go there and where the new w
it'll be launched wy more in terms of
correction that we see here the term of
correction it's alpha that will handle to
how fast will we learn in which
point we will change allow us wy
sees the difference between the real
answer at least the prediction and times
finally the entrance to which were
connected our weight w so there m
entered for our example tm
drive so xti this is the 3rd
elements of the vector xt and so we're going
shoot like that
until we're actually
all our dances
training and that if we have
actually we'll shoot like that
until we reach a certain
khiter stop is one of the criteria
stop that sometimes used it's
to simply say that I continue
until the number of errors is
0 where we can simply identify
a maximum number of iterations then
the a10 terrisse according to this number
of iterations so the equation we see
here it's called the rule
learning tax collector and then
the alpha here it's called the
learning rate we say to
learning because it determines to
what speed will be changed to
how much will it be changed our
settings what speed do we want
learning will take place so we
will here look at the rule to try
to have a little an edition why
could it work so
consider the case where yt would be equal to 1
imagine we made a mistake so
or h2x so existed would be zero
so in this case this is actually what is
arrived is that we wanted to predict a
but wxx was smaller xero so the
exit after the threshold was 2 hours
so what we would like to do in fact
is to increase what is in input of
the function if we would like wxx
be bigger so what does it mean
in fact, we would like to change
our each of our weights wy for that
next time we want to multiply
wxx polish a result that is more
big that will get closer to zero for
it is hoped to exceed the threshold of 0 then
get an exit that was galley
so we have the term existed less
bought which gives us in what
direction is what we want wxx to
directed
and there now for the weight ebay w if
the input to which connected xti
is positive but in this case we
want to increase w ok but if the input
was negative in this case one
would like w to be smaller because
if we increase and w
the result of wx now extract
further from zero it would decrease and so
that's why we have to multiply
also, for example, six positive countries
but know 1 - 0 times something
positive
still a term that is positive so we
will increase w what is the
desired behavior because six
ex-country negatives because if we
would like wy to decrease and so we
would have a positive number times a number
negative so we stop everything will end
here which is negative so double very
would decrease and there now you can
do the exercise for the body or what
would be the greens ie the
target after 10.0 instead we would have
predicts one and in this case also you
will see that again the rule here
and there the good behavior
that is to say that we will indeed tried
to change that term here two to
inside the sun to change a
side of the threshold that's bad of the
wrong answer to one side of the threshold
which is good ie which produces the
good answer is finally I just
points out that finally one more way
succinct decree is our rule for
describe a rule about w and say that
it applies to all possible on
can the vector forms crises on
says we're going to take the vector of
w parameters is what we will do is
we will calculate we will add the
excited vector times
yt minus the prediction made the
learning tour so that this rule
to vector shapes that's what gives
exactly the same result as
to apply the update we saw
in the previous slide but for
each of the positions there in our
actor w